why don't more people care about my
thing it's unbelievable the way the rest
of you just blissfully live your lives
unconcerned with the real issues of this
world after all take any aspect of your
life my group would agree that my thing
is the most pressing thing about it
don't you all realize how serious this
is
I mean let's not even talk about people
with a different opinion of my thing the
fact that they don't agree with my facts
means that they're willfully ignoring
the facts no I'm talking to you the one
with no dog in this fight really you're
the one to blame here you keep talking
about your thing and going on about that
but you have to realize by not taking
action on my thing you're perpetuating
the problem inaction is action and
you've done quite enough already
I guess silly me for thinking that other
people would actually be logical and
reasonable for a change and realize that
my things should be as important to them
as it is to me it just breaks my heart
why don't more people care about my
thing
[Music]
[Applause]